المكان جبل عرفه والزمان يوم عرفه حيث
وقفت جموع الحجيج من كافه الاعراق في محطه
النسك الثانيه منذ صبيحه التاسع من ذي
الحجه استمع حجاج بيت الله الحرامي الى
خطبه جامع نمره وقاموا بعدها صلاتي الظهر
والعصر جمعا وقصرا وتلهج الالسن بالدعوات
والابتهالات
[موسيقى]
كون
قال الله تعالى ومن اياته خلق السماوات
والارض واختلاف السنتكم والوانكم ان في
ذلك لايات للعالمين وان مما تتابعت النصوص
على تاكيده
الامر بالاجتماع والمحبه والتالف والنهي
عن التنازع والتفرق والاختلاف اكثر من
مليون وثمانمائه الف حاج يجمعهم مكان واحد
ليوم واحد رغم تعدد لغاتهم واعراقهم
وانتماءاتهم وتعدد انماط حياتهم في حشد لا
يتكرر شيوى على هذه البقعه المقدسه التي
لا تتجاوز مساحتها 11 كيلومترا تتم ادارته
بسلاسه فضلا من الله
ورحمه منه يسر لنا ان نكون ضمن حجيج هذا
العام من السودان رغم الظروف اللي كانت
حاصله في بلادنا لكن يسر الله عز وجل
العقبات وذل للصعاب
وتمكنا ان نكون بين ركب الحجاج ملبين
وحاجه حلوه عن الحج والله ربنا ان شاء
الله يوعد كل مشتاق ان شاء الله وربنا
يتقبل منا جميعا من جميع كل واحد حضر
الحجه ربنا يتقبل منه ومننا ومن امه محمد
جميعا نشكر الله ونحمده على انه شرفنا
بهذا المكان
وطبعا ربنا يعودها علينا مرات كثيره ويرزق
اولادنا وجميع خلقه بهذا المكان وحج بيته
الحرام ربي يتقبل
دعائنا وان شاء الله ربي ينصر جميع الامه
الاسلاميه
تميل الشمس الى الغرور ولا يزال الخشوع
والسكينه يغشى يعني افئده الحجيج في اقدس
واطهري بقاع الارض مشهد مهيب هنا في مشعل
عرفات ورغم حراره الشمس المرتفعه
هنا يستعجل الغروب فهذا هو اليوم المنتظر
والاحباب الذين اوصوا الحجاجه بالدعاء
كثيرون ولافده والعقول لا يشغلها الا نيل
المغفره والقبول بدر ربيعان الجزيره من
امام جبل الرحمه مشاري عرفات